welcome back to pft live nbc sports
radio from the league meetings in
arizona and the big news in the national
football league involves new england
patriots the decision of rob gronkowski
to walk away from the game after nine
seasons who better to help us understand
how we got here and where the team goes
from here
than somebody other than tom curran but
tom is all we could get tom curran
nbcsportsboston.com here with us tom
great seeing you as always great to be
here mike corporate cousin
nbc city this is the way it works man
it's synergy baby quid pro quo back
scratch and you name it just don't ask
me for anything so what happened to
cause rob gronkowski to retire that's
fascinating to me because of the timing
you know gronk was of a mind that he was
going to take his time and figure out
what was going on my understanding was
he wasn't going to rush things the
patriots didn't rush to make things easy
for him over the past few years he was
going to take his time well the patriots
wanted to know at the beginning of free
agency what's interesting about the
timing is earlier on sunday mike reese
put out a report that jared cook tight
end from the raiders
was leaning towards signing with the
saints because he just didn't know what
was up with the patriots and rob
gronkowski so it was starting to impact
their free agent shopping to a degree
this uncertainty with rob so i wonder if
the patriots said to him look you got a
pooper get off the pot here we're not
going to sit here and have our team held
hostage by you which in my mind he had a
great opportunity if he did hold him
hostage to increase his leverage and
change his contract from 9 million to 12
13 14 more in line with impact players
he chose not to do that did he choose
not to do that
because he wanted to leave it on good
terms did he choose not to do that
because as willie mcginnis broached a
few weeks ago
he might come back later in the season i
don't think that that's the most
ludicrous idea i've ever heard
to take off this time and then come back
i'll out jason witt nala any number of
players who don't retire retire and it's
funny tom the way you were laying that
out it reminded me of when the packers
gave that same request to brett favre in
2008 in february and i think it was
calculated
to provoke from him a retirement
decision but if bronk decides at some
point to come back he just shows up he's
reinstated and they have to decide what
they're going to do with him and it's
one thing to say he'll come back later
in the year at a time when maybe the
patriots want him what if they do move
on what if they do have a plan that they
implement and he decides to show up when
they don't want him that may be a way to
engineer your exit to another team not
that he's ever shown and that's a
creation to want it great question i
think what we have to do then is pivot
to the football conversation they're
screwed they're in a horrible horrible
position right now and i'm sure there's
people in new england said oh yeah tommy
said the same thing last year and they
they hoisted a super bowl trophy and
they had another parade fine but right
now julian edelman is the only guy you
could say is somebody you want to put
stuck in philip dorsett's a nice third
or fourth receiver maybe they signed
bruce ellington maurice harris
offensively they have sony michelle
that's nice good okay you got a running
game and you can block and still have
tom brady but you're also missing the
left tackle from last year rob
gronkowski was everything upon which
that offense pivoted along with julian
edelman now you have a 33 year old slot
a 42 year old quarterback what's the
plan i don't know
but they had to know this could be
coming so there has to be some semblance
of a plan i mean well thinking is that
maybe
they'll they'll replace him in the draft
i think maybe you could try to find a
veteran somewhere and and also draft
somebody i know but i've looked through
it because this has been a shoe that's
been waiting to drop there's nothing
really there and i think this is where
the patriots take advantage of the
success and ability of josh mcdaniels
and tom brady to an extent that is
mind-boggling that you're going to go
into a season in 2017 with cordaro
patterson
um philip dorsett and chris hogan as
your wide receivers and rob gronkowski
is your running back with jeremy hill
who got hurt and sony many michelle's
your running backs and say you'll figure
it out they did figure it out it's
astonishing
do you see the patriots looking at the
rosters out there and maybe trying to
find somebody they could trade for 100
but i thought that would be a receiver
situation you're nelson aguilera's
maybe even an aj green but less likely a
sterling shepherd those kinds of the
players at the wide receiver not a tight
end
not that i've started kicking rocks over
yet because travis kelsey i was a big
wow well it's a lot of money going out
but if you lose tyree kill you can't
bring a tyre what about kyle rudolph i'm
just thinking past catching tight ends
guys that are out there that maybe the
team would like to clear their salary
cap number off the books jared cook is
still not and you know this could come
to pass at some point on monday that he
does become official but jared cook's
still not official so if gronk or it
could or it could happen before monday
morning making this entire segment
irrelevant so thank you for going down
that path
yeah but i i really weighed my i really
weighed i had enough i put it through my
head i put it through the filter i said
what's the worst that could happen you
need to thicken your filter
um let me peel back the curtain here
we've already done this interview once
today before rob gronkowski retired but
regardless
it's fair for us to say
that
as of the time we're having this
conversation on sunday afternoon west
coast time there is a chance that jared
cook could sign his contract finally
with new orleans saints if he does not
the patriots could swoop in and try to
take him and maybe that's why cook
hasn't signed it precisely and that's
why i hedged my bets figuring it was
about a 17 chance that between now and
then he would sign
okay so um you think they'll be okay no
but
but they always find a way to be okay
they always have a plan tom what's that
thing that they say about financial
um
investments
previous whatever is no indication of
future returns yeah past performance
notifications right right fastest
prologue bill paul this past year was a
difficult year for now maybe josh gordon
comes back and he's uh absolute straight
arrow boy scout he looks like he did in
2013. and they find a great title they
get irv smith from alabama and isaiah
win goes to left tackle and plays great
i didn't think trent brown was going to
be a good left tackle last year voila
so all those things can happen i just
know when you take what i think could be
argued it's the best tight end of all
time and if you put up mackie and ditka
and kellen winslow and antonio gates and
and uh tony gonzalez none of them i
think
is better than gronk and certainly none
of them has been a better better big
game player than gronk you take that
player off your offense both as a
blocker and a pass catcher
that friggin hurts but what did he do he
didn't do much last year in the regular
season he really didn't it was his worst
year do you know why because they didn't
have anybody to start the season so he
got triple teamed for four games at the
beginning of the year he's caught seven
for 123 in the first game he got his
body beat up everybody blamed him all
season long for them sucking and then by
the time his body did feel better and he
finally said you know what i'm really
getting hosed here that was a big
problem mentally he felt as if he was
getting hosed he didn't have time to
heal during the week dwayne allen and
jacob hollister were the only guys that
tight end behind him so there's nobody
else taking the rep so it's like croc
you're practicing today gronk we need
you to practice today he's like
i can't do it anymore
finally he got his brain around it and
stopped being miserable but he had a
very miserable season he's been
miserable since 2016 when the patriots
picked up the back end of his contract
and he's tweeted at that time was dwayne
allen's contract was he signed with the
colts and gronk said wow looks like i'm
actually taking a pay cut so since march
of 2016 to now he's felt underpaid this
kind of was hitting critical mass
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports